quand tu es amoureux de quelqu'un tu es
aussi intoxiqué par lui par son odeur
par les phéromones qui se mélangent qu'est-ce que l'
amour
quelqu'un que vous aimez mais
il y a quelqu'un d'autre là-dedans
[Musique]
en ultra carbone, il est possible que l'
esprit humain soit déplacé d'un corps à l'autre
Je suis l'incarnation originale de
Takeshi Kovacs connu sous le nom de naissance Kovach
quand il rencontre Kel deux polaires  des
personnages opposés qui ont enfin l'impression d'avoir
trouvé quelqu'un qu'ils aiment se concentrent sur ce qui
vous tient le plus à cœur dans ce monde
250 ans passent et Takeshi est
ramené dans le corps d'un
flic en disgrâce Riker Kovich est à l'intérieur de la manche d'Elias
Riker et c'est mon ex-  petit ami
tu sais que c'est très compliqué parce que
quand je le vois c'est le corps de la
personne que j'aime mais quelqu'un d'autre le
vit à l'intérieur Kristen Ortega donc il
y a une attirance physique
absolue qui les rapproche où  eas leurs
personnalités sont complètement en désaccord d'
abord, c'est comme une relation amour / haine
toi et ta fille êtes morts ensemble elle n'est
pas ma fille pas en tant que fille je ne les
aime même pas c'est un triangle amoureux très intéressant
parce que c'est un triangle amoureux
dans le même  personne désolé je suis mon parti pris
l'histoire redéfinit si joliment et
avec désinvolture notre relation à
notre physique quand vous pouvez être dans n'importe
quel corps que signifie aimer quelqu'un que
vous